Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Hi.
I'm nervous.
I choose karaoke streams to make me less nervous sometimes,
but then also the karaoke stream itself makes me nervous.
This is a dollar for every night that I've listened to you
sing, Harvest Moon.
Should I sing it tonight as well, even though it's not the
Harvest Moon?
Today, I've chosen a little bit more of a chilly vibe.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Remember that time you did karaoke to calm your nerves
before Big Dana worked out like that?
actually I know but I get nervous for the karaoke too I
might lose service by the time you start but me too is cool
I don't know if you're still here hello what's I gonna do oh
I was gonna do this I'm
gonna eat a throat drop not drop Is this open?
A cough, not a cough drop.
This one's open.
I have so many things for my throat.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift and thank you!
Hello everybody, welcome in.
Karaoke!
Let me just, uh...
Let me...
just i don't know why i get so nervous it's also because
like also today i have no plan i have no plan and
i'm just i'm just we're just winging it remember to drink
lots of water and tea huh i am i got a big little give big
big cupa big cupa right next to me about Densetsu.TXU
tomorrow.
I have to warn my bank!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Invisible Moose, thank you so much for the 20 here today,
Kube.
It's weird.
things like this are so strange.
Like, planning stuff.
It's always like, and this doesn't just go for, like,
VTubers, but, like, Oh my gosh, Dermatio, thank you so much
for the 50.
Thank you!
Oh, that's right.
Oh, chat froze.
Why does it keep happening?
And freeze!
There we go.
Oh, wrong chat.
Oh my gosh, I just realized.
I think it's the... I think I was practicing.
I think that is the debut chat.
That's so funny.
Oops.
I just didn't even question... Ah, there you guys are.
I didn't even question it.
oopsie but um you know when you're like this is like for
projects for anything you know you like spend all this time
prepping and all this time stressing and all this time
preparing and then as soon as it comes it's over in like you
know for me it'll be over in an hour and it's like all this
and for me it's also weird because like
Phoebe's changing a couple things Vicky is straight up
debuting but for me not much is changing so I'm like why am
I nervous not much is really changing for me I guess you
know the sound of saying debut or it's like the start of
something new in a sense because it's the start of the three
of us together but
but in terms of like streaming and stuff nothing's gonna
change you're gonna make a lot of fans pregnant tomorrow
tomorrow why i'm seeing sweet caroline sweet caroline
It happens.
You are about to start a new journey.
I guess that's kind of true.
That is kind of true.
Not kind of.
It is true.
I mean, it is the start of something new.
We're gonna do our best with it.
You're nervous because it's going to be awesome!
And you're always nervous before awesome things.
I...
You know, I have a few new things prepared.
A few new things to kind of make it a little bit shinier.
For the most part, I didn't want to make it seem all new,
because, you know, like I said, for the most part, things
will be staying the same.
So, make today a graduation stream.
No!
You guys would kill me!
I'm already dead!
And you would be like...
You would be like...
But, um...
Yeah, where's the white background and the smiling and the
slight breeze in my hair?
And our little hearts.
I don't even want to joke about stuff like that, so.
Excited for it.
Have fun.
Yeah, we'll just have fun.
Minto karaoke before Denza 2.exe.
You're spoiling us.
MVP.
Yeah, MVP.
Please know.
No, no, no, I'm not.
Densetsu.exe, does that make...
Densu.exe, does that make...
Mint the ghost in the machine?
Ah!
The shorts you guys have been releasing and build up to
tomorrow's debut had me dying of laughter.
A lot of the shorts, basically...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like we should release an extended cut or something
because the shorts are all basically...
Most of them are taken from one...
session.
The three of us kind of met up and then just like talked for
like an hour or something.
Minto was always an idol, but soon more will know.
I don't know.
Yeah, a lot of stuff was cut out.
Um, it felt like a podcast.
Yeah, we were just like, we were just chatting about
everything and anything.
We were just like,
Oh!
Oh my gosh, before I start singing, can I show you guys
something?
I can finally show you this, which is kind of crazy.
Hold on.
I can finally maybe satisfy some curious folks.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for all the super chats, you
guys.
Thank you, Shiny Dears.
I should start writing things down, huh?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Release the Minto cut.
Thank you so much.
Okay, hold on.
Not the wet wang.
so there was a collab bond
yes okay all right here we go this might look familiar to
some of you all hopefully all of you so i hope all of you
watch this oh wait hold on whoa familiar familiar right some
of you might have i saw a few comments some people noticed
that there was a point of silence.
Oh my god.
Spooked, man.
Oh, nope.
Not yet.
Wait, there we go.
I can satisfy all your curiosity.
I actually had to censor that, or I had to silence that
manually.
Once again, changed locations and I got to sing with my
favorite girlies.
ever phoebe and vicky thank you guys did the two exe yeah
that's it i
was like we were stressing actually we were high key
stressing we were like they were like you have to cut the
song and i was like i can't cut the song and so ultimately
it i felt so terrible ultimately it it made it so that vicky
would like like and everything early, like, it was, it was,
it was, we were like, what do we do?
What do we do?
Because we were like, do we keep it a secret?
Like, super secret until, until everything do, we had to,
all because of that.
Literally all because of the song.
And then I was like, well, I can't cut the MC afterwards.
Like, it wouldn't make sense.
But then I don't know.
So.
We kind of figured out, as you see what happened, that's
kind of how we decided to do it.
Yeah, I'm so sorry, Vicky.
I think she was okay with it, though.
I think she had a lot of fun making all of her videos and
everything.
Calling Din Setsu Da Ixia 3A.
I'm not clickbait.
Where can I see that cover?
That's a great question.
You can see that cover in my 3D debut.
live stream oh hi vicky wait let me let me let me put you
here so i can see you there we go save i was happy to be in
the concert no matter what yeah and thank you for being
there that day too i really appreciate it like supporting me
throughout the show too you know and everything in
it oh wait oh my gosh vicky i bought something else okay
Like, you guys, I...
I got Vicky a Shadow the Hedgehog.
Hold on, let me look at that.
It's like a stretchy Shadow the Hedgehog.
I was like, I bought this for you.
And then she was like, oh my gosh, I've seen these before on
TikTok.
People will cut off his limbs and then fill it with water
and watch him expand.
And I was like, but also, Vicky, I went to the Lego store
recently and I got you a little Lego...
I got you a little Lego shadow.
yeah don't google shadow inflation let's go yeah oh my gosh
you guys have to see vicky's debut tomorrow not just because
she's so stinking cute but oh my gosh it's so good oh it's
so good thank you my I got you!
I got you!
Do not Google shadow inflation.
I wonder what you would get.
Maybe you'll get the TikTok video.
Just dig around a little bit.
Membership placeholder for Vicky Roman.
Idol.
Yeah!
Do you really wonder?
Maybe.
Gotta go prep for debut.
Yeah!
See you, see you, see you, see you, later.
See you, see you, see you tomorrow.
See you tomorrow.
I don't want to dig around.
Victoria Roman.
Oh my gosh, I want to sing our new song.
I want to sing like, I wonder actually though if I could
sing like the...
I wonder if it's like a type of song where you could sing
the full version.
Time to learn I am all of me from show.
on that talk i think she i think vicky's got that covered
i've been so excited for densetsu.exe and vicky yeah since
the three-part harmony you guys didn't have a music box of
fate yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh yeah the song also our song i
you could hear it too i'm so excited oh my gosh i'm so
excited for you guys to hear the full version of the song
because I really love the chorus but it didn't show my
favorite part in the preview obviously we can't save we
can't show you the best part for the preview but okay what
should I sing what should I sing what should I say oh let's
sing let's just no I don't want to sing this one we'll sing
sweet Caroline bread bread
week Caroline since someone asked for earlier.
I'm not, oh wait, I'm not like, uh, I am doing requests, but
not like a formal requests thing.
It's kind of just, kind of, just, we're just going to go
with the flow of that's okay, you guys.
Kind of, kind of just doing whatever I want.
Just doing whatever I want.
If that's all right, if that's all right.
Okie dokie I wish
I knew the Hugh Jackman version Where it began I can't begin
to know when But then I know it's growing strong When it was
the spring.
And spring became the summer.
Who'd I believe you'd come along?
Touching hands.
Reaching out.
Touching me.
Touching you.
Sweet Caroline.
Breadbread.
The times never seem so good, so good, so good!
I've been inclined, bread, bread, bread To believe they
never would, but Look at the night And it don't seem so
lonely We fill it up with only two the bread thing after
sorry and when i hurt hurting runs off my shoulders how can
i hurt when holding you warm touching warm reaching out
touching me Keep touching you.
Sweet Caroline.
Bread, bread, bread.
Good times never seem so good.
So good.
I've been inclined to believe they never would.
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh.
I wonder if we could even find karaoke versions a lot.
Sweet Caroline, ba ba ba, the dance never seems so good.
So good!
And go!
Sweet Caroline, I believe they never could.
Caroline The dance never seemed so good So good, yeah
I forgot to ask How was the audio?
How was the sound on that?
I was just like using it as a test song And I got so into it
I forgot to test if it was too loud or not
It was good?
Okay, good, good, good Okay, so Hugh Jackman played he's he
is in a maybe it's released now i don't know an upcoming
maybe question mark movie about neil diamond or a guy no a
guy that played an impersonator of neil diamond i'm so
confused the song was the song my family sang my grandma for
her birthday oh so sweet huge jacked man name.
Yeah.
And Hugh Jackman played the guy.
Oh, gosh.
Jean, Jean, Jean, Jean, Jean Valjean in Le Maze.
And, and the way he sings is very, like, specific.
Jean Valjean.
Yeah, Jean Valjean.
And, oh, prisoner six, two, eight, oh, one.
why should we sing some lemmas but um so because Hugh
Jackman has this very specific way of singing and he sings
sweet Caroline he's like sweet Caroline and there's like
this guy who sorry this is like the most convoluted
explanation ever but there's this guy who does like parody
videos of Hugh of like like pretending or acting like he's
or singing like how Hugh Jackman sings and then replaces the
lyrics to songs with bread because that's what happened in
Le Messe is Jean Valjean got arrested because he stole a
loaf of bread and so as a bass singer that song is like what
do I go to it's really it's like such a hype song everybody
knows sweet Caroline
And he's like, I stole a loaf of bread.
It's so funny.
The way he sings is so specific.
I stole a loaf of bread.
Okay, oh gosh, my brain rot is very multi-layered.
Yes, yes, indeed.
Francis Hardcore, man.
I don't know.
Do you hear the purple sing?
Singing the song.
What is that one?
I don't even know.
I could sing.
What is a L'Ameselable song?
Um.
Song of Angry Bread.
Sing on my own.
Okay.
I'll sing.
that wait that's such a it's i feel like it matches the
vibes of my sad winter setup
and now i'm all alone again nowhere to turn no one to go to
without a hope without a friend without a face to say hello
to but now the night is near now i can make wait oh gosh
sometimes i walk alone at night when everybody else is
sleeping i think of him and then i'm happy with the company
wait what's the what's the note here the city goes to bed
and i can live inside my head
on my own pretending he beside me all alone I walk with him
till morning without him I feel his arms around me and when
I close wait let's wait I've said the wrong word in the rain
the pavement shines like silver all the lights are misty in
the river in the darkness the trees are full of starlight
and all I see is him and me forever and forever and I I know
it's only in my mind that I'm talking to myself and not to
him.
And although I know that he is blind, still I say there's a
way for us.
I love him, but when the night is over He is gone, the river
is just a river Without him, the world around me changes The
trees are barren everywhere, the streets are full of
strangers I love him, but every day I'm learning All my
life, I've only been pretending Without me, his world will
go on turning A world that's full of happiness that I have
never known
I love him I love him Solid snake I love snake But only
on...
The self-insert.
Yeah, sorry.
Got a little carried away there.
Let me... I also realized I forgot to turn off...
I haven't heard one, but I forgot to turn off sounds for the
doughnuts.
So let me...
Do that real quickly.
One moment.
I don't even know if one has shown up or not.
I don't know if they're like buried beneath a bunch of
stuff.
Minto sounds like a princess?
I do.
Thank you.
Wicked?
Oh, don't even.
Oh my gosh, wait.
My wicked brain right, though.
for it now which wicked song which wicked song be nice if
they made a mute all toggle i know right i feel like at this
point they could but okay save and then i have to remember
what because they're not all the same volume save save save
popular i love popular we could do multiple oh my gosh a of
people saying popular okay i'll do popular popular uh oh
wait do i do the ariana grande version or the christian
chenoweth version um
i'm more familiar with the original so i'll do that version
whenever i see someone less fortunate than i and let's face
it who is Less fortunate than I, my tender heart tends to
start to bleed.
And when someone needs a makeover, I simply have to take
over.
I know, I know exactly what they need.
And even in your case, though it's the toughest case I've
yet to face, Don't worry, I'm determined to succeed.
Follow my lead And yes, indeed, you will be popular You're
gonna be popular I'll teach you the proper poise when you
talk to boys Little ways to flirt and flounce I'll show you
what shoes to wear How to fix your hair Everything that
really counts to be popular I'll help you be popular.
You'll hang with the right cohorts.
You'll be good at sports.
Know the slang you've got to know.
So let's start because you've got an awfully long way to go.
Don't be offended by my frank analysis.
Think of it as personality dialysis.
Now that I've chosen to become a palisester and advisor,
there's nobody wiser.
Not when it comes to popular.
And with an assist from me to be who you'll be Instead of
dreary who you were, well, are There's nothing that can stop
you from becoming popular LAR La la la We're gonna make you
popular When I see depressing creatures With unprepossessing
features remind them on their own we have to think of
celebrated heads of state or especially great communicators
did they have brains or knowledge don't make me laugh they
were popular right that's my favorite part of the movie
version it's not about aptitude it's the way you're viewed
so it's very shrewd to be very very popular like me Oh my
gosh, my Miss Alphaba.
Look at you.
You're beautiful.
Oh, whoa.
I have to go.
There's a lady here.
Oh my gosh.
You're welcome.
And though you protest your disinterest, I know
clandestinely.
You're gonna grin and bury your newfound popularity.
La, la, la, you'll be popular.
Just not quite as popular as me.
I forgot to turn on reverb.
Oh my god.
Woman jump scare, woman jump scare.
That's another wicked song.
I forgot to warm up for today's stream, so I apologize in
advance.
My favorite part of karaoke streams is seeing all the great
names go, Make it sing!
No!
Is that Glinda?
Look, it's Glinda!
Denny, the reverb?
Thank you.
That's not true.
What a wicked karaoke.
Defying gravity?
Galinda Galinda Look it's Galinda Let's see I can try
Defying Gravity I can't Should I I guess the music or the
musical version is like what makes the sorry wait I'm I have
a million thoughts right now What is the difference between
the film?
Because it's so much longer.
It's like seven and a half minutes long.
Go, Linda.
Go for it.
Thank you so much for the mic, Kat, and thank you.
I want to hear her sing that note.
The dialogue.
I can, let's see, let's see.
I might have to do both parts.
Oh, gosh.
Elphaba, why couldn't you have stayed calm for once, instead
of flying off the handle?
I hope you're happy, I hope you're happy now, I hope you're
happy how you hurt your cause forever, I hope you think
you're clever, I hope you're happy, I hope you're happy too,
I hope you're proud how you would grovel in submission to
feed your own ambition, so though I can't imagine how,
right now.
I had to add a voice.
Elfie, listen to me.
Just say you're sorry.
You can still be with the wizard, what you've worked and
waited for.
You can have all you ever wanted.
I know.
But I don't want it.
I thought there was a cat in my room.
I can't want it anymore.
Oh, I was early, sorry.
Hold on.
My gravity.
Something has changed within me.
The pacing is all different.
It's not what I'm used to.
something is not the same I'm through with playing by the
rules of someone else's game too late for second guessing
too late to go back to sleep it's time to trust my instincts
close my eyes it's good and then one and leave it's time to
try defying gravity I think I'll try defying gravity and you
can't pull me down can't I make you understand you're having
delusions of grandeur I'm through accepting limits it's
slower Someone says they're so Some things I cannot change
But till I try I'll never know Too long I've been afraid of
Losing love I guess I've lost Well if that's love It comes
at much too high a cost I'd sooner buy Defying gravity Kiss
me good Oh boy, I'm defying gravity And you can't pull me
down This is, this is hard Why is it so slow?
Think of what we could do together Unlimited Together we're
unlimited Together we'll be the greatest team there's ever
been dreams the way we plan them if we work in tandem
there's no fight we cannot win just you and I defying
gravity with you and I defying gravity they'll never shut up
they'll bring us down I couldn't remember whose harmonies I
was doing.
Are you coming?
Well, are you guys?
Are you guys?
Are you coming?
I hope you're happy.
What is the note here?
Now that you're choosing this, you too.
I hope it brings you bliss.
I really hope you get it and you don't live to regret it.
I hope you're happy in the end I hope you're happy, my
friend No, let her alone!
She hasn't done anything wrong!
I'm the one you want!
This part's gonna make me laugh!
It's me!
Me?
So if you care to find me, let the
one deserve the chance to fly.
And if I'm flying solo, at least I'm flying free.
To those who'd ground me, take a message back from me.
Tell them how I'm defying gravity.
I am defying the revenue And soon I'll match them in renown
I am not suited for Elfaba I'm more suited for Glinda, I
think Unlimited
Unlimited Unlimited
Oh, nobody in all of us know wizard that there is or was is
ever gonna bring me
down.
Did you guys ever see the commercials of Cynthia Arrivo
being like, No, that's my line.
But people would like slow it down.
They'd be like, no, that's my line.
That's all I can think of.
Tarsan.
Oh, gosh.
Hello, by Adele.
The original singer is one of the highest vocal raids on
Broadway.
Oh, Adina Madel, she's, like, insane.
That lady.
Sorry, I was, like, laughing.
I was, like, laughing, like, half the song.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, gosh.
I'm still nervous, so it's like...
Oh, gosh, okay.
Oh, my God.
much for the 30 gifts and thank you thank you guys so much
brother super chance thank you we played your karaoke of
golden hour at our wedding what
but first of all congratulations but
oh my gosh
wow thank you
Okay, what should I sing next?
I kind of want to sing Disney.
Oh, wait.
I think I know what I want to sing.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
I have to make sure it's the right one.
One second.
Okay, okay.
I think so.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm double checking.
Okay, wait.
Did I...
Did I miss it?
Okay.
I got it.
Evermore!
I'll sing that one after.
Actually, maybe I should sing it first.
Can we play your song at our wedding?
Really?
Yeah, I mean, sure.
If you want, I feel like you should get a hire a
professional okay here we go
who's the leader of the club that's made for you and me
m-i-c-k-e-y m-o-u-a-c hey there hi there hold there you're
as welcome as can be m-i-c-k-e-y m-o-u-s-c Mickey Mouse!
Micky Mouse!
Forever than a solar banner high, high, high, high!
Come along and sing your song and join the Jam Marine.
M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E.
Mickey Mouse Club, Mickey Mouse Club.
We'll have fun.
We'll meet new faces.
We'll do things and we'll go places.
All around the world we're marching.
Who's the leader of the club that's made for you and me?
M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E Hey there, hi there, home there,
you're as welcome as can be M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E, Mickey
Mouse Hello Jack!
Mickey Mouse!
Hello Jack!
Forever let us hold our banner high, high, high, high Come
along and sing your song and join the jamboree M-I-C-K-E-Y,
M-O-E-M-O-E-M-O-Y Hey Becky!
The cold children.
Now it's time to say goodbye to all our humble...
M-I-C.
See you real soon!
Tell me why.
Why because we like you.
M-O-U-S-E.
The ending is so scary.
It's like the...
Why is it such a cursed song?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'll sing evermore.
Wait, which is the right version?
I don't remember.
I think it's the right version.
I don't think I have to change the...
I always think this.
I'm like, do I have to change the pitch?
The key.
I only wanted to sing the Donald Duck.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I close my eyes but she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
It's more than I can bear.
But now I know she'll never leave.
me even as she runs away she will still torment me call me
hurt me move me come what may wasting in my lonely tower
waiting by an open door I'll fool myself, she'll walk right
in And be with me forevermore I rage against the trials of
love I curse the fading of the light Though she's already
flown so far beyond my reach She's never out of sight Now I
know she'll never leave me Even as she fades from view She
will still inspire me Be a part of everything I do Wasting
in my lonely tower Waiting by an open door How full myself
she'll walk right in And as the long, long nights begin I'll
think of all that might have been Waiting here forever
My lung capacity
Evermore.
Yippee!
All I ask of you are...
Twilight!
Wait, what's all I ask of you?
Wait.
I feel like I know that one.
Oh!
Phantom?
Oh, geez.
Getting all the...
The toughies, huh?
It's not easy being green.
I don't know that song.
Everything's alright from To The Moon.
I didn't learn it yet.
A rainbow connection?
Wait, oh my gosh.
This song is so sweet.
Wait, can I do it as Kermit?
Do I remember this song?
Why are there so many songs about rainbows and what's on the
other side?
Rainbows are visions but only illusions and rainbows have
nothing to hide.
So we've been told and some choose to believe it.
I know they're wrong, wait and see.
Someday we'll find it.
The rainbow connection.
The lovers, the dreamers, and the frogberg.
Who said every wish is true?
Would be heard and answered When wished on the morning star
Somebody thought of that And someone believed it Look what
it's done so far What's so amazing That keeps us stargazing
think we might see someday we'll find it the rainbow
connection the lovers the dreamers and me
i don't know this part wait oh my god have you been half
asleep or have you heard voices.
I've heard them calling my name.
Is this the sweet sound that calls the young sailors?
The voice might be one and the same.
I've heard it too many times to ignore it.
It's something that I'm supposed to someday we'll find it
the rainbow connection the lovers the dreamers and me
it's not kermit that was kermit the frog actually i have a
secret that wasn't kermit the frog that was frog burt and
and he sounds just like kermit a return from no service
house let's go literally anything bruno mars that's a bruno
mars song i don't think i've ever sung a bruno mars besides
die with a smile but have i sung this one wait can i sing
this one
She never fails to impress.
Really?
Were you impressed?
Hold on, wait.
Do I know this song?
Game start!
Oh, I'm a too, a I'm a too.
Uh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Kissy face, kissy face, send to your phone, but I'm trying
to kiss your lips for real.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Red hearts, red hearts, that's what I'm on, yeah.
Come give me something I can feel.
Don't you want me like I want you, baby?
Don't you need me like I need you now?
Sleep tomorrow, but tonight go crazy.
All you gotta do is just meet me at the...
Oh,
that's pretty nice.
Turn this up, I'll put it into a club.
I'm talking drink, dance, smoke, freedom, the girl was up.
Don't you want me like I want you, baby?
Don't you need me like I need you now?
Sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy.
All you gotta do is..
Just meet me.
I thought Apochu, Apochu Apochu Apochu, Apochu Apochu
Uh-huh, uh-huh Apochu Apochu Apochu Apochu Uh-huh, uh-huh
Uh-huh Hey, so now you know the game.
Are you ready?
Because I'm always gonna get ya!
Get ya, get ya, get ya Hold on, on I'm on my way Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm on my way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't you want me like I want you, baby?
Don't you need me like I need you now?
Sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy.
All you gotta do is just meet me at the opportunity.
I don't know that
song well at all, but it's such a fun time!
it's all for fun anyway today hold on I want to listen to it
how what is what is rose is it rose or hold on does she do
the do the what's it called the harmony here oh she does oh
that's what I was missing rose sorry I was
Do what?
Oh, she does sing it.
Wait, maybe I should sing Bruno Mars' part then.
Maybe I should sing Bruno Mars' part then.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Oh, let's see what else.
Wait, I kind of want to sing Levera.
Is that okay real quick?
A little break.
A little break with Levera.
Crying, I'm not sure if it's from laughter or how pretty you
sang Rainbow Connection.
earlier thank you so much for the for the for the spooky
dono i will sing i'll do a christmas where i christmas
karaoke where i sing the nijicon song oh my gosh lazy town
let's see i don't think i've sung this levi song before so i
wanted to sing it if that's okay
city June is dawning down on me and all that I can a sickly
romance in the air lover stroll wait stroller where can I
start over I didn't mean to say stroller like they're a baby
can
I start over sorry moved
out to a new city June is dawning down on me and all
A sickly romance in the air Love or stroll without a care
inside Ooh, this can't be right Cause the sun's engaged to
the sky And my best friends found a new guy I'm only getting
older a shoulder to cry on someone to calm my everybody's
falling in love and I'm falling behind touch
the ocean fell right in stepped outside and burned my skin
my life won't go bossa nova in my room hope that i'll find
someone too to love because the sun's engaged in the sky and
my best friends found a new guy i'm only getting older i've
never had a shoulder to cry on to come back everybody's
falling in love and i'm falling behind everybody's falling
in love everybody's falling in love
Everybody's falling in love
Me One, two, three
Yay Okay, I didn't mess up the second time But it was really
hard to not To not To not laugh
Yay, yay, yay Stroller Don't say it!
I wonder what else...
What other...
Levi...
I haven't done this one.
Actually, I haven't done a lot of these.
Oh!
Mintney Spears, maybe.
Odoriko, I thought about that song earlier.
Snow White?
That's literally the song.
hovering over oh my gosh i'll try it i'll try it i'm never
sung about this one i'm gonna do with reverb though this is
a sad song can't help but notice
in which i failed myself i failed the world all the same
It's not up for debate.
A woman's best currency is her body, not her brain.
They try to tell me, tell me I'm wrong, but mirrors tell
lies to me my mind just plays along the world is a sick
place at least for a girl the people want beauty skinny
always wins and i don't have enough of it i'll never of it
Sometimes I see her She looks like snow white She's
everything I am But my wrongs are turned to rights Her body
is smaller skin is so fair.
She's achieved everything I've dreamed of and it's all that
I can think of.
They try to tell me, tell me I'm wrong, but mirrors tell
lies to me, my mind just plays along.
The world is a sick place At least for a girl The people
want beauty, skinny always wins And I don't have enough of
it I'll never have of it
This song is so sad
Lavey, are you okay?
Let's do a happy song next.
What's a happy song?
TK rep.
So true.
Oh yeah, you didn't say Twilight, right?
earlier.
Wait, I think I have to like adjust that song to...
Was it electric light?
Was it taken down?
Oh my gosh, I don't say it anymore.
Oh no, there it is.
Just kidding.
Ha ha ha.
of time, twilight crawling through my window pane.
Am I awake or do I dream?
The strangest pictures I have seen, night is day and
twilight's gone away.
With your head held high and your scarlet lies, you came
down to me from the open skies.
It's either real or it's a dream There's nothing that is in
between Twilight I only meant to stay a while Twilight I
gave you time To steal my mind Away from me
Across the night I saw your face Face, you disappeared
without a trace Trace, you brought me here But can you take
me back?
Inside the image of your light Now that, now that it's the
hey, you have my dyslexia You let me hear and then you go
away It's either real or it's a dream There's nothing that
is in between Twilight
I always, this song is such an otaku song, right?
I'm not the only one that thinks that, right?
You brought me here, but can you take me back again?
With your head held high and your scarlet flies, you came
down to me from the open skies.
It's either real or it's a dream, there's nothing that is
here.
in between.
Twilight, I only meant to stay a while.
Twilight, I gave you time to steal my mind.
Bye-bye.
Twilight, I only meant to stay a while.
I only meant to stay a while Yeah!
You guys know!
I can't tell you how many times I watched that Daikon video
Like an insane amount of time
It's so good Reminds me of simpler times Reminds me of all
the good things times man oh my gosh watching the den setu
video makes me want to sing something like kind of nico nico
and that song also makes me want to sing kind of nico nico
opportunity nicholas lures happy birthday happy happy
birthday happy birthday and encapsulation of pop culture
from that time right
I think you'd love her music.
Oh, write it down.
Same vibes as Levera?
Okay.
I don't know it.
I'll look it up.
Thank you.
Now all my neighbors know about Otaku Music!
What's a...
Do you know, Linger by the Cranberries?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Killy Killy Joker!
I almost sang that song for my 3D.
That's crazy.
I almost...
Why did I switch?
I don't remember I almost sang that one though Linger Linger
I think I I know that one I'm pretty sure I think so I might
get some of it wrong I'm sorry
I'm writing some more songs down Bye.
If you...
If you could return Don't let it burn Don't let it fade I'm
sure I'm not being rude But it's just your attitude It's
tearing me apart It's ruining everything And I swore I swear
I would be true Now honey, so did you So why were you
holding her hand Is that the way we stand?
Were you lying all the time?
Was it just a game to you?
But I'm in so deep You know I'm such a fool for you You got
me wrapped around your feet Do you have to let it linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
Oh, I thought the world of you.
I thought nothing could, wait, go wrong.
But I was wrong.
Wait, I didn't remember this part.
I'm sorry.
you if you could get by trying not to lie things wouldn't be
so confused and i wouldn't feel so used but you always
really knew i just want to be with you and i'm in so deep
you know i'm such a fool
around your finger Do you have to let it linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
But I'm in so deep You know I'm such a fool for you You got
me wrapped around your finger Do you have to let it linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
You know I'm such a fool for you You got me wrapped around
your finger Do you have to let it linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
I know what I'm going to sing next.
Oh, wait, which one was it?
Was it this one?
Wait, which one was it?
Is it this one?
Don't remember.
I think so.
I'll
be closer.
Hear what I have to say
Just like children we sleep in We could dream this night
away
But there's a full moon rising Let's go dancing in the night
Where
the music's playing Let's go out and feel that night
Because I'm still in love with you I want to see you dance
again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest
moon And
we were strangers I watched you from afar
Now it's getting late
I want to celebrate See it shining in your life Because
I'm still in love with you I want to see you dance again
Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon So
much for the best he gets in the dark
Because I'm still in love with you I wanna see you dance
again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest
moon We'll get all these similar ones out of the way Similar
vibes.
Oh
my gosh, groove and magic!
I heard this song recently.
Over the county.
And I drive the main road, searching in the sun for another
overlord.
I hear you singing in the wire I can hear you through the
wire And the witch's alignment
Is still on the line
I know I need a small vacation But it don't look like rain
And if it snows that stretch down south won't ever stand the
strain And I need you more than want you And I want you for
all time And the wretched alignment It's still on the line.
And I need you more than want you And I want you for all
time And the witch in alignment Is still on the line
Hey, thank you guys.
Thank you.
That was a Wichita Lineman.
Wait, that was like a back-to-back.
Wait, what was I?
What did I do?
Back-to-back.
Linger, Harvest Moon, Wichita Lineman.
I realized, I think tomorrow I'm going to save the Nico Nico
songs.
I want to sing a couple songs tomorrow, so I think I'll save
it for then.
I already picked out what songs I want to sing, so.
songs that I have that I want to sing so I'll save it for
tomorrow Killy Killy Joker though so I remember that well
enough I didn't like learn it learn it because I you know I
know the chorus for sure
soft heart song wait Killy Killy Joker It's stinking Kanon
Wakashima, so it's like, well, she doesn't wait, what's the
other song?
She doesn't, uh, let's...
Hi, Miss Alice, Anna, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, ma, da,
da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, Wait, can I
kill a Joker?
Is there an instrumental, let's say?
There is.
I don't think I can sing it, though.
Not today.
Tomorrow's my birthday!
I should have Happy early birthday Happy early birthday
I think I could do still doll though I think I remember it
Cause I I did that song like crazy I wasn't even a vampire
night Girlie even But I'll try it Let's see Oh my gosh, it's
so...
I haven't heard this song in like a decade.
Let's see how well I can do it.
I miss Alice.
I'm so happy to be here.
I'm still a heartless, My heart's heart is s-
S-ke-ske-ske-ske- It's a-nagare-tere-tere It's a great space
It's a great space.
I think I didn't choose Killy Killy Joker was because one of
Wakeshima Kanon's She is a beautiful cello player So it was
mostly cello then singing And I was like, oh my gosh, I'm
gonna have to come up with like Crazy choreo for it
I miss Alice I'm with a flower, I'm with a fruit, I'm with a
flower.
Who's giving me love?
I'm giving you.
I'm still you do not answer
Oh, sorry, I forgot to change the song.
That was still dull.
Dull.
Still dull.
Oh, my gosh.
I seriously haven't heard that song in like a decade for
real.
I can't believe I remember so much of it.
Wait, that kind of makes me want to sing something else.
Hold on.
Oh, gosh.
What's it called?
I wonder.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Stop reading my mind.
Yeah.
Even our website is like that we will have up and
everything.
like make make make it like old old akiba old like geocities
the only thing i remember about vampire knight was the guy
knowing he would live longer let her marry and live for 90
years until he died and then then then be with her i
remember they were cousins that's that's what i remember
yeah just that's what i remember too oh man hold on i'm
gonna drink some of my my syrup wait worse than just cousins
no way i remember the betrayal way more that reminds me of
like uh so basically into the in the detective conan fujoshi
fandom they hardcore ship uh conan and uh kaito kid right
and then in one of the recent movies in one of the recent
movies they were like by the way chichi slash conan and
kaito kid their cousins they had like a meltdown I thought
they were siblings Are they?
Were they siblings?
No way Wait, actually?
Do I need to watch Vampire Net?
They were cousins.
Oh, good.
Kissing cousins.
Hands.
Touching hands.
Reaching out.
Kissing cousins.
Kissing you.
I'm still eating my syrup, hold on.
Don't do that.
Don't kiss your cousin on the lips.
Oh.
Carol Lambert.
Wait, Carol.
Carol Alabama.
So should I sing Sweet Home Alabama?
I just finished binging Matt Cross and apparently being
cousins never stopped some people.
Wait, should we sing a Macross song?
The composer for our song, Anita-san, is one of the
composers for Macross Delta.
Let's see.
I want to do a frontier song, sorry.
I should sing a Macross song.
What do I sing, though?
Oh my gosh, there's so many, I just see, I like, like what
about my star, like everything, I, oh, oh, it's so good.
Hmm, how do we request a song?
Um, you can just kind of say it, and sometimes I pick it,
but I don't always, I'm not like doing request requests, but
thank you so much, I'm glad you didn't like it, thank you.
We could do a triangle.
triangle let me chance you do colorful in them oh maybe
hmm you can
have borderline I always do you can have borderline no
not not YouTube giving me dead emas dead emas oh Danko Danko
Sama So cute Um I could do Lion Maybe Triangular Maybe Hmm
That one is Kimi I don't know Wait I don't remember Is there
a bridge I don't know if I'll remember it though
Congratulations on tomorrow Minto Thank you Thank you so
much Which, uh...
Matilda the Musical.
I'm sorry, I don't know it!
I could do Lion since there's like a...
There's already a karaoke for it.
Wait, what's... How's Lion go again?
Wait, how does Lion start?
Oh,
now you're spamming.
The timeout you go.
Christmas songs.
We'll save that for Christmas.
I feel like I've sang that one quite a bit recently too.
Okay, I'm going to sing Lion.
I'm going to try and remember.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Wait, did I sing this one recently then?
Why is it showing that I've sung it?
I want to sing one that I don't sing often.
Oh wait, oh my gosh This is one like that You don't hear
very often
Hopefully this is an actual instrumental It says it is
I'm more, I'm more
Is my key off?
Oh my god, the lyrics they give you were bad.
They're slow!
Why the hell did I choose a song?
It's been so long, I can't even remember it.
Ah!
Sorry.
I used to listen to this one a lot, so I thought that I
would remember it, but I don't know.
And
it all come back to me.
Hit me.
But it didn't.
Sorry.
Is this the same person?
It is, but they're the only ones uploading these
instrumentals!
Okay, hopefully this one's better.
This, this is so crazy.
Oh my god, I gotta look up, hold on, I gotta look up the
lyrics.
Oh my gosh, they're so slow, I can't follow.
they're so they're so slow to to come up on the screen i'll
start it over sorry oh my god it's impossible to follow okay
there we go
sorry sorry about that i was trying fix your fix your thing
actually wait let me see if there's better quality version
if I'm not even going to follow the...
Wait, try...
To...
Karaoke.
Toraoke.
Tora...
Is this
right?
Oh, it's Angura.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is this right?
Hold on.
One second.
I'm checking.
Oh,
nice, nice, nice.
I found one.
Okay, I found one.
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
It's got a cool, funky intro too.
Yawamushi, naki, mushi-tolerate I'm still going to think I'm
more than I think I'm more than I'm more than I'm more I'm
more than I'm always, Tayasui, I'm just a bit too much It's
a bit of a bad thing, but I'm not going to be able to get
out of it, but I'm not going to be able to get to get me.
I'm just going to get you.
If it's not my fault, then it's not my fault.
My feelings are the ones who kiss me.
I'm not the one who's the one.
The heart of the world is more than The responsibility is at
the end of the day Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da Hi, baby In the
wildsoul sabak-o-o-ke-kid In the back of the game, In the
out-dash-dash-koying Yoroke-tah with the breath.
With the breath, it's all full.
Come here and come here and get it.
It's so hard to see.
It's so hard to look forward.
The way you're looking for with a smiling voice.
I can't remember the future.
It's my mother right now.
I'm just gonna hold me And I'll be the same thing
You're the one who's the one who's the one who's the one
who's the one, that's the one, that's all the other.
The tears are like a yakuza, the other.
The stars are the same.
Uh-oh, is there a bridge?
I don't know if I remember it.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Da da.
KISSO KISSO KISSO
KISSO KISSO KISSO KISSO I,
Oh, I also forgot to change it again, I'm sorry.
Try, try, train.
Triangler.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Such a classic.
A real classic.
A classic.
Triangler.
It's triangular, guys.
The.
Triangler.
No, no.
I spelled it correctly.
Triangler.
What is there?
Is there another?
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
I kind of want to sing Seikahiko because of Phoebe.
You know what?
I will.
Let's see.
There's gotta be it.
Northern Cross, how does that sound go?
Say kan hiko!
.
Together, Kira!
Rune Rune Rune Rune Rune Rune Ah,
ah No, no No, no Horsi So that we, We're a Harabee Like
Makoro the Hikari The Hara Rune Turu, Turu, Turu Rune
Rune Rune, Turu, Turu Rune
Inside the watery, inside the river.
That's a divine story, it's so interesting, It's your
Turo-triad-i-ne-mongu-gene no repeat In the purse garrison-t
kurz-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-tri-
I'm so happy.
Even though our lives are still like our hearts are still
just like my soul.
When the universe is flowing, I'm again and I'm still alive.
And I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
We're all together.
I'm happy.
The heart of the light will release The fire, fire,
fire The kashin'zou of my life The kashin' tach, mata'
tachin' tachatakatakai tachin' tada Oh, baby!
The kashin' the kinsatakai tachin'atatare tachaiaiai
Hi, baby!
You sing, Macross, Frontier, and Phoebe will appear.
Say Macross, say Macross three times in the mirror fast.
Macross, Macross, Macross, Macross.
And Phoebe will appear.
Yeah.
Yay.
Thank you.
You summoned me.
Yeah.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
One second.
Okay.
You guys, I got, like, the cutest email today.
I got the cutest email today.
And it was just like, hello.
We are from high school.
Would you like to be a guest speaker for my e-sports, for
our e-sports class?
Of course I'm going to do it, but they were like, it's kind
of an urgent matter.
But they didn't tell me when.
Of course I'm going to accept.
And then they were like, here's the address to the school.
If you cannot show up, you can Zoom call.
it was
so if you are listening esports class of that school which I
will not say any way at all of course I will join your class
I will zoom in I will zoom call in do you know anything by
Peramore oh Why?
I don't know, let's see.
I also, I'm not an esports student.
I've never done esports, that's a lie.
I've done esports once.
I've barely, I've done like one tournament before.
I'm not, I don't know why I'm being invited to the esports
class.
I didn't even know, high schools had an esports class.
I'm excited to hear what you have to say about esports.
They're probably gonna be like, how did you become a
streamer and I'm going to be like luck baby it's all about
they're not going to like that answer though huh work hard
work hard and you know I kind of know ain't it fun but only
a little bit I could try it I could try it why not singing
new stuff.
I don't want to always sing the same songs that I do, you
know?
Ain't it fun?
Let's try it.
I don't mind.
Let you down easy, but just give me time.
If it don't hurt now, then just wait a while.
Oh, am I singing this right?
No more.
what they're beating on.
So what are you gonna do when the world don't orbit around
you?
You, you.
So what are you gonna do when the world don't orbit around
you?
Sounds good?
Okay.
Ain't it fun?
Live that in the real world?
Ain't it good being all alone?
Where you're from?
Oh, you might be the one who's running things Well, you
can't ring any bell that's just what you want Nor trouble
Gonna do when the world Don't orbit around you Uh-oh So what
are you gonna do When nobody wants to fool with you?
Ain't it fun Living in the real world Bada bam, bada bam
Ain't it good Being all alone
Ain't it good to be on your own?
Ain't it fun you can't count on no one?
Ain't it fun living in the real world?
Pitta bam, pitta bam.
Don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own in the
real world.
real world So don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on
your own in the real world Stop go crying to your mama Cause
you're on your own in the real world Ain't it fun, ain't it
fun?
Baby, now you're one of us Ain't it fun?
Ain't it fun?
Ain't it fun Living in the real world Ain't it good?
Being all alone And in
the real world Don't orbit around you.
Do it.
Oh, I don't know this part.
All alone.
Don't go crying to your mom.
On to your mother.
In the real world.
To your mama.
Cause you're on your own.
In the real world.
Someone in the background is like really be loud cause
you're on your own in the real world don't go crying to your
mama cause you're on your own in the real world this is the
real world to your mama cause you're on your own in the real
cause you're on your own in the real world
Don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own In the
real world
Yeah I don't know that song like I don't She has so many ad
libs at the end I was like I don't know like any of these
That's fine.
Yay!
This kind of makes me...
Let's see, uh...
Did I spell it wrong?
What do you mean there's no results for my chemical romance?
What the...
What do you mean?
Huh?
What?
What do you mean?
That's like not possible.
Really?
Try MCR.
Did they rebrand?
No, I get Tate McRae.
I don't know who that is.
No way.
That's craziness.
But that's okay.
I want to do some...
You know what?
I say I don't want to sing all the same songs all the time.
But there are some songs that I do want to sing.
That are some of the ones that I like.
We'll do this one I know you guys will like.
Emo isn't real mint.
No!
It wasn't a face!
If there's a prize for rotten judgment, I guess I've already
won that.
No man is worth the aggravation.
That's ancient history.
Been there, done that.
Who'd you think you're kidding?
He's the earth and heaven till you try to keep it hidden.
Honey, we can see right now.
Oh no!
We know how you feel and who you think you know.
No chance, no way, I won't say it, no, no.
You swoon, you saw why deny it, oh.
It's too cliche, I won't say I'm in love.
I thought my heart had learned its lesson.
It feels so good when you start out My head is screaming,
get a grip, girl Unless you're dying to cry your heart out
You keep on denying Who you are and how you're feeling When
we saw your head was clear I said, I could grow up Wherever
you go, I'll do what you got by me Oh, no chance, no way I
won't say it, no, no Give it Check the grin, you're in love
This scene won't play I won't say I'm in love
Your way, your face, I won't say it Get off my case, I won't
say it Girl, don't be proud, it's okay
At least out loud I won't say I'm in love
Do you like my acting?
Zero the hero?
I don't know if I've ever done that one before.
Zero the hero.
He was a zero.
Zero, zero.
No, he's a hero.
Okay, I might mess this up.
Let's try it.
Bless my soul.
Herc was on a roll.
Person of the week and every green.
opinion poll.
What a pro.
Hurt could stop a show.
Point him at a monster and you're talking SRO.
Here was a no one, a zero, zero.
Now he's a honcho, he's a hero.
Here was a kid with his act down pat from zero to hero in no
time flat.
Zero to hero, just like that.
When you smile, the girls went wild with ooze and eyes.
And they slapped his face on every on every of us.
Repairance fees and royalties, our herk had cash to burn.
From Noburu, rich or famous, he could tell you what the
Grecians are.
Say amen, there he goes again.
So you don't defeat it at an awesome 10 for 10.
Folks lined up, just a one with chip flecks.
This perfect package with a pair of pretty pegs.
Herky he comes, he sees he conquers.
The crafts were go-wake balkers.
I don't know this part at all.
Zero to hero, a major hunt.
Zero to hero, and who to thug?
Who want the gladding gladiator?
Hercules.
Who daring deeds are great theater?
Is he bold?
Is he sweet?
Hercules.
Hercules!
Ow!
I don't know.
Hercules!
Bless my soul, Herk was on a row, undefeated, riding high
and the nicest guy, not conceited, he was a nothing, now
he's a honcho, he's a hero, he's a hero, he's a breakneck,
speed, from, oh, from zero to hero, Herk is a hero, now he's
a hero,
Yes, indeed.
Oh, my God.
Oh, geez.
I'm out of water.
Are we just going to sing all Hercules songs?
Oops, all Hercules.
I want to sing other dance.
Disney.
Out there from Hunchback.
I'm scared.
I have trauma with that song.
And my voices start to dance.
give out a little bit so i'm like well i'd be able to hit
the notes oh god hold on let me get some more water oh wait
actually hold on i can oh oh oh no no my throat spray i
do not know build me up buttercup i'm sorry okay i think out
there might be my final song if that's okay guys because my
voice starting to get a little scratchy And I want to sing
tomorrow, too.
Basically, oh my gosh, you guys don't even...
Oh, oh, oh, every, every...
Oh, my gosh, I'll be like, okay, I got to record this.
And then one extra thing I have to record.
Like, I'll be like, okay, I'm going to put away my...
I'm going to put away my recording stuff later.
And then I have to pull it all back out to record.
Oh, I pull it back out to record.
Pull it so many times.
So many times I've been like, oh, I have to record this.
Oh, I have to record this.
yesterday i recorded like two three songs or something like
i've been recording like crazy i'm i'm so no and i have to
record more saturday i have to record two more songs
saturday so it's been like it's been just non-stop recording
for me
stuff will be like extra takes for like the original song or
like they'll need extra stuff or will we have some other
things that we will be showing off tomorrow and the day
after so the original song will be on Saturday by the way so
make sure you watch the group collab so that you can catch
the original song
but uh Yeah, so it's like, so, uh, we have stuff that we're
still down to the wire finishing up, but it's just been
like, mad.
It's been, it's been, yeah, and I'll, I'll be like, okay,
back to recording, take a break to eat, back to recording,
take another break or something, get back to the recording,
so much recording, so much.
uh hopefully hopefully it's all worth it hopefully you guys
like everything and yeah yeah you're at a wedding this this
weekend you should tell the dj to play densetsu mvps be like
dj put this on it's the hottest song right now
so yeah i I'm very excited, obviously, about everything.
I, you know, I didn't expect some people's reactions to it.
I was really happy, you know, that so many people were, um,
were really excited for us.
But I think, you know, there are some people that are kind
of nervous because of, um, Because of, you know, we've had a
couple setbacks.
I've had a couple setbacks in the past.
But I want to kind of reassure you guys that, you know, a
lot of planning went into this.
And if we weren't so sure about it, like, we wouldn't have
gone through with it.
and um you know i i had i i was on i remember being in my
hotel room and i i was like seeing people's responses i was
like whoa and it makes sense because to us we understand
what's going on and to you guys you're probably just like
what is this what is happening what is going on um so uh it
probably seems like a little more obviously it's official
but like a little more how to say like because we're not
corporate so it probably it might seem that way but you know
we still all own our IPs and everything we we're very much
still you know even I think you know like even if Setsuna
were to pull out we would still be Den Setsu if we wanted to
be so yeah i know that some people are quite weary about
corpo corporations and everything right now um but but well
like i said we were we um satsuna has been really great with
us and uh so far and um things won't change for my content
at all um except just adding more stuff for you guys so uh
so yeah i just wanted to like i was like having an anxiety
attack at the hotel room i was like because i don't know i
just didn't expect to us you know obviously we know what's
going on behind the scenes so we know what's happening and
then so i was like oh my gosh i didn't expect people's
reactions and i was like wow wow it just it threw me through
a loop but um yeah so uh we're we're very confident that you
know that things will be awesome and we're excited for
everything so we just want to take you guys along on the
journey so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah not and you know well
yeah yeah i was gonna say something and then i lost the i
had the the second part of the thought and i did not have
the first part of the thought and thank you guys so much for
the donos i do see them thank you thank you thank you
magical circle guru guru i'm sorry i don't know thought of
train yeah but yeah i guess uh you know it kind of came out
of nowhere and i guess it's appeared different than how it
actually is so um you know uh maybe maybe if we look like
we're corporate that means we have our stuff together
because behind the scenes we're kind and believe it looks
like we we look so official that we look like we could be
corporate but but behind the scenes we're like we're like
scrambling little ants we're all over the place can't
control thank you so much for that guys so much happy to see
you three get the debut as idols can't wait to support you
along with everyone else mvp yeah it'll be the first idol
group i follow thank you oh my gosh can't wait to see yeah
so it still feels bizarre to me even still feels very
strange a lot of this stuff a lot of this stuff was well not
a lot there was a handful of things that were being prepared
a long long time ago and then kind of everything got thrown
into a blender and so kind of to kind of throw pick up the
pieces and try to puzzle them back together and see what we
can salvage and what we could still use and we oh man you
know i love i'm really happy with our song so much i love um
the work that anita san has done we did have another artist
that i was so excited to work with um maybe hopefully we can
still work with them one day it was like a dream artist of
mine so i was like i was like unfortunately it didn't work
out but i honestly i don't even mind because the song is
just that it's just that so it's just that good i can't wait
for you guys to hear it oh i can't wait for you guys to hear
it it's so it makes your heart go go blah and then And
then...
And...
So...
It's a fun song!
It's so fun, it's so fun.
This will be the first underground idol group I follow!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, you can hear it in my voice.
Oh geez, will I be able to sing this song?
I wonder.
I'll do my best.
Let me do another throat spray.
Cover with Nimi!
Thank you!
Now whenever I hear on my own I'm going to think of Epinian
longing for soul to sing.
No, it's me!
It's me!
Okay.
This will be probably my last song.
I know I wanted to actually sing much longer.
I don't even know how many songs I've done.
Maybe a few.
Hmm.
And I'll sing some more tomorrow.
Just a couple songs, though.
Just a couple.
It sounds exactly like something you'd produce just all
kinds of woosh and wah woosh and wah woosh and wah yeah
so okay last song last song save your voice for tomorrow no
no no it's okay it's okay I just I am okay I just don't know
if I'll hit the note because we'll see we'll see we'll see
Let's try.
I'm stronger now.
Connection lost.
Wait, what?
What do you mean by that?
Am I still streaming?
Am I still live?
Wait, what do you mean, connection lost?
I am?
Oh.
Maybe...
Hold on, let me see.
Let me open Carol Fun Up again.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, it's just starting.
Okay, let's go!
Safe behind these windows and these parapets of stone Gazing
at the people down below me All my life I watch them as I
hide up here alone Hungry for the histories they show me All
my life I memorize their faces Knowing them as they will
never know me All my life I wonder how it feels to pass a
day Not above them But part of them And out there Living in
the sun Give me one day out there All I ask is one To hold
forever Where they all live are nowhere What I'd give What I
dare Just to live one day out there
Out there among the millers and the weavers and their wives
Through the roofs and gables I can see them Every day they
shout and scold and go about their lives, heedless of the
gift it is to be them.
If I was in their skin, I'd treasure every instant out
there, strolling by the sand.
Taste a morning out there like ordinary men.
Who freely walk about there Just one day and then I swear
I'll be content With my share Won't present, won't despair
Hold and bent, I won't care All has meant for us
I can't hit that damn note I can't do it I can't hit that
sticker now it haunts me it haunts me that stupid ass note
thank you guys almost there literally But that's not the
name of the song.
The song is called Out There.
Oh, the trauma of the song.
Ah, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
I'll do it better next time.
It's such a high note.
It is.
It's like a knot in my...
I could hit it if I don't use my head voice.
You know?
Like I use...
Like the way I sing the song.
Like...
You know, it's very easy if I sing with my chest.
chest voice but with my head voice it's like so high and
then I always forget to switch so oh well whatever I give up
I give up it's not like I'm gonna be it's not like I'm gonna
be singing it's not like it's not like I have a group to
depend on me or anything for my voice it's not like it's not
like I'm gonna be concerts or...
Yes!
Yeah, I'm not like, it's my job!
Okay, wait.
I want to do one more.
I want to do one that I can end on that sounds good.
What's a what?
What's a song that I could sing.
Oh,
What's a song?
Oh.
how the end of my brain is.
My brain is braining?
Killy, Killy Joker.
I literally said I didn't learn it.
Shut up.
I'm going to put you in timeout.
It's also mostly...
It's mostly cello.
A love live.
A love live song.
Love live What's a love slap song?
I scream, scream, scream my show
Wait!
You guys, I think I have to sing this song Given the Given
our location
It's like the right now.
It's like the sky came from the sky.
Woohoo!
A special season of color is the toky-meky, I'm gonna show
you the first time I've met you at the time from the feeling
I can't even hear the sound of the melody I can't stop, I
can't stop, why?
Why don't you tell me how it's so sad?
The name of the song, the song, the song When the feelings
are going to happen, I'm not waiting for you.
I'm not sure, but I love the truth In the heat of the world
Can't be too bad, no doubt about it To be called, I'm ready
to sing I'm almost at the start
With no sound, no, no No, no, no No, no, no, no, no No, no,
no,
no I'd like to be there, wherever, wherever.
Fly high, I'd say that it's no matter.
I'm a big one.
I'm too big.
I'm a true emotion.
I'm a dreamer, I'm a dreamer.
It's very hard.
I just
remember something.
Oh, shoot.
I'll just remember something.
I wish I was ancient history I'll have a greater time
Yay!
That reminds me that...
I'm glad I have a manager now because I don't respond to
emails sometimes.
I get busy.
Yeah.
Otomito everybody!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
I might have gotten an email from a certain someone who
likes a girl and done.
I don't know!
Cypher!
Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday.
Densutsu.exe, I'll see you there!
See you there, see you there, see you there.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
You better be there.
You better be there, all of you, every single one of you.
Bye-bye.